people of the Internet's hello and
welcome back to fortnight fundamentals
your one-stop shop for all the basics of
fortnight in today's video we're gonna
be taking a look at the building
component of the game this will be a
first in a series of videos on building
I'm gonna do my best to break it down
from all angles so you can understand
the very very basics of building and we
may even touch on some of the more
complex building components later such
as editing so for starters when do you
need to build well building can be used
for a variety of reasons but let's try
and keep it simple
there are really three primary reasons
that you should be building one is to
use it as an attack mechanism two is to
use it as a defense mechanism and three
is to use it as a traversal mechanism
the most talented players of fortnight
are actually able to do all three of
these things at once launch an attack
while protecting themselves while
totally changing their position it's
pretty impressive when it's pulled off
but these videos are all about the
basics so to start we need to explain
how do you build well it all begins with
harvesting materials throughout the
world and today's video is going to
focus on the three different types of
materials that you can harvest wood
stone and metal as you can probably
guess wood is the weakest of the three
followed by stone and then metal being
the strongest but just how different are
they wood is plentiful yet it's also the
weakest of the three brick is slightly
harder to find and harvest but it's a
little bit stronger than wood and
finally we have metal which is arguably
the hardest to find and the strongest of
all three materials just how big is the
difference well let's take a look we'll
start by placing this wooden wall and as
you can see it has 150 total HP it also
reaches the 150 fairly quickly now if we
hit left on the d-pad we're actually
able to switch the material from wood to
stone or brick as some call it
notice that this one is 300 HP we're
gonna go ahead and place it as well and
then finally we have metal which is 500
HP now you see the wood is already
complete the brick is just finishing yet
the metal is still progressing toward
its maximum strength
so while wood is the weakest it also
builds the fastest brick builds a little
bit slower and then finally metal builds
the slowest of
all now epic recently changed up how
materials work you see previously wood
was actually the strongest when first
placed that has now changed and it
certainly makes more sense the way to
set up now because now metal is the
strongest on immediate placement
followed by stone followed by wood
it's one thing to look at numbers but
how does it actually matter in the game
well let's take a look here I'm gonna
pull out my pickaxe and I'm gonna see
how many swipes it takes to destroy this
wood you see there it took me two swipes
now let's go over to the stone one swipe
two swipes and a third swipe so three
swipes versus two and finally on the
metal we're gonna go one two three four
so four swipes four metal
three swipes four stone and two swipes
for wood now that of course is with the
pickaxe but what about when using
weapons let's go ahead and build another
set of walls and we'll do another set of
tests here this time I'm gonna pull out
a standard grey assault rifle and I'm
gonna get fairly close and I'm gonna
take shots as soon as this one completes
building here on the metal see it's at
350 370
at how slow it takes metal to reach its
maximum strength and now it is hit 500
of course the stone is already complete
and the wood was complete a while ago
alright so I'm gonna back up here and
then take a couple of shots with this
grey assault rifle you see on the wood
each shot of the assault rifle is doing
thirty damage so we drop in 150 to 120
to 9262 38 and then destroyed now with
brick it does the exact same damage the
only difference is the brick has 300 HP
rather than 150 and finally with the
metal same situation here the AR does 30
damage so your weapon hits for the same
amount of damage regardless of which
type of material so when you're using
materials for defensive building
you should try and use metal if you have
it followed by stone and followed by
wood if you have no other option now let
me just tell you right now it's not
always gonna work out that way simply
because wood is so much easier to find
and the other two materials but if
you're getting down to the last couple
of players and see you have a lot of
metal or stone available then you might
want to go ahead and switch to it in
preparation for your next battle that's
gonna be it for this building video but
rest assured we're going to have plenty
of other videos on building in this
series there are so many intricacies to
the building component and it's a vital
part of the
I'm gonna be honest it can be difficult
to become a master builder to get where
you want to be we'll take an
understanding of the basic ideas behind
building and probably lots of practice
in playground mode I should also add
that the large 50 V 50 modes are perfect
training grounds to practice your
building it's a step up from playground
mode but it's a little more relaxed than
solos duo's or squads alright everyone
thank you for taking the time to watch
this video I hope it helps you
understand a little bit more about how
building works in fortnight go ahead and
give this video a like below share it
with your friends and definitely
subscribe to the channel good luck with
your next drop nice
[Applause]
1v2
nice
oh let's go I thought there is still one
more up oh my goodness